MATT STEPHENSON: Good afternoon
and welcome.
My name is Matt Stevenson.
I'm a software engineer.
I work on the Java runtime
for Google App Engine.
Today I'd like to talk about
something that's been very
important with what I work on
and what I've worked on in the
past, which is how to build
applications that autoscale
very well in Java.
Autoscaling is an incredibly
important piece of Google's
internal infrastructure.
It allows us to efficiently
utilize the resources that we
currently have internally.
An autoscaling environment is
an environment with the
capability to expand
and reduce capacity
based on user demands.
This is done by
overprovisioning machines, typically.
And for us it's really great,
because we get to have really
effective utilization
of our resources.
For some of you that
might be important.
But for many of you,
that may not be the
most important thing.
You may have only one
application that you're running.
It may not make sense to
overprovision and have
different applications consume
your resource pool over time.
So I'll give you
a little story.
A while back, I used
to work for a large
online internet retailer.
And I was on call.
And it was a holiday week.
And it was a little bit rough,
as it usually was.
But they sold a lot of this
new device that year--
a whole lot of this
new device.
And I ended up getting paged.
This device had a large group of
services that supported it,
running behind, running inside
of our infrastructure.
And those services were
scaled pretty well.
That's what the team thought.
But they had a big concern.
And I was paged--
kind of in a scramble to get
resources and be able to
deploy their service to many,
many instances in a very short
period of time--
because they had sold a lot of
these devices, but not a lot
of them had been
turned on yet.
And the reason for this was that
many of them we're still
on the packaging.
And so over the next few days
at specific times, they were
expecting these services
to get hit really,
really, really hard.
So in that sense, autoscaling
would have been a magical
thing for us.
I would not have been paged.
It would not have been so much
use of engineering resources
and so much of a scramble to
try and find additional
computational resources
to support
this influx of requests.
So what does this
mean about Java?
How does Java play into this?
Java has an interesting
evolution.
We started off really small
and simple with applets.
Those consumed a very small
amount of memory.
And the JVM was optimized
for that.
And then we went from there and
grew into a much larger
vendor-specific enterprise-
Java
Enterprise Edition servers.
And JVM was optimized
to fully consume
these pieces of hardware.
It was optimized for
CPU and memory.
And that evolution continued.
But at the same time, we started
having this really
popular thing called
the internet.
And so really the only thing
that people were building with
Java Enterprise Edition were
web application resources.
And so we started to have
containers that were
optimized for that--
things like JBoss and Spring
Application Server.
And all of that kind of evolved
to build out to fully
consume compute resources
again.
But in that case, it was more
commodity hardware.
It wasn't the big
application-specific mass of
machines you were purchasing
from these vendors.
And again, the JVM was optimized
for memory and CPU
utilization.
But now we're kind of in a new
generation of Java runtimes
and Java VMs, or usage of the
VM, where you're seeing very
small containers--
things like Jetty--
just running very small
frameworks, like Drop Wizard
and things like App Engine
coming around.
Along with that, now you're
seeing a lot of Java
development in another platform
that's about the same
size, if even larger than what
you usually have in an
overprovisioned infrastructure
as a service or
platform as a service.
Because like your mobile phones
today are massively
more powerful than say a Google
Compute Engine micro
instance or an App Engine F1,
or even an F2 instance.
And again, Spring and
JBoss and such are
still very widely used.
And they are very,
very effective on
larger pieces of hardware.
So what does this mean
for App Engine?
App Engine has a Java runtime.
We can automatically scale
to meet your needs.
And it works pretty well
for the average user.
You're not really going
to see much limitation
when it comes to that.
So let me give you a quick demo
of what that looks like.
I'm just using a pretty simple
tool here called jMeter.
And if you haven't messed with
it yet, then you probably
should take a look.
All I'm going to do here is
hit my App Engine instance
that's running, with about 1,000
concurrent users, 100
times over.
So let's just do that
real quick.
So as you can see, I'm pounding
it pretty hard.
And let's go take a look
at App Engine here.
And we can take a look at how
many instances I have running.
I'm hitting the normal version
of my application.
So I've got a good deal of
instances running here.
And these are all pretty
healthy instances.
They're all responding
pretty well.
So let's take a look at what
this looks like in a graph.
And as we can see, we had some
loading requests that hit.
We were thankfully you
know, subsecond.
And everything seems to respond
just perfectly fine.
So what are some problems when
it comes to trying to build a
JAVA application that runs on
top of an overprovisioned
environment or a platform as a
service that utilizes very
light resources so that you can
do very cost effective and
very powerful autoscaling?
Large deployments can
be very complicated.
And in that I mean, deployments
that have a very
large amount of resources
allocated to them--
things that where you have
a very complex dependency
structures--
automatically instantiating
classes can be overly complex,
and can be very difficult for a
platform as a service to be
able to keep up with.
Code generation can be very
problematic because in many
times, you're going be spinning
up and spinning down
instances very quickly.
So runtime generation of code
can be very, very, very
difficult for the runtime
to keep up with--
as well as if you have
Security Managers
and things like that.
Managing shared state can be a
big problem, and persisting
configuration both can
be [? moral ?]
problems, not really specific to
the Java world, but more in
general when it comes to just
having that many cross
connecting, that much crosstalk,
with the individual
instances coming up.
So large deployments--
this as an example of just some
Maven that I've seen in
applications that I've had
to take a look at.
And these kind of dependencies,
whenever you
have really complex dependency
structures and you end up with
a lot of artifacts, it can be
very, very difficult to track
down what's going on.
This is kind of actually what
I prefer in terms of Maven
dependencies--
something really lightweight,
using just Guice with Jersey
and Jackson.
This is more like for if you're
building in like a
RESTful web service--
if you're building it from
scratch, not necessarily using
cloud end points.
Let me show you real quick
what it looks like--
what I'm talking about
in terms of what's
going on here in Maven.
So I've got an application
that's got a pretty complex
dependency structure.
And I can kind of see that
because all of a sudden, I'm
kind of just downloading the
entire world to try and get
this application built.
Now if I really want to make
sure, if I really want to take
a look at everything and see--
I'm sorry, that's a
little bit small--
if I want to see what's going
on really in my dependencies
in Maven, that's actually
really easy.
A Maven dependency plug-in can
give me a really good idea.
And there's a whole lot of IDE
integrations that make this a
lot prettier.
But as you can see, this
is relatively complex.
If I wanted to try and make this
a lot simpler, I'm pretty
sure I could.
So let's take a look here.
So along with that, the other
problem that I see a lot is
automatically instantiating
classes.
This is kind of a problem
because it can get a little
bit of control.
And if you're using frameworks
to do a whole lot of work for
you to instantiate and destroy
classes, and manage the life
cycle of those objects, you're
going to have a lot of
problems refactoring later on to
try and make sure that you
are not accidentally creating
objects and such.
And one of the things that
always gets me about this is
is that "New" is a really
fast operation in Java.
So this is kind of an example of
something that I see a lot
of people doing, where
you have a--
my goodness, OK.
This is a problem that I see a
lot of people have with Spring
applications.
This is an example of using
an annotation to try and
automatically instantiate
a class.
So what this is is, you have a
class that's annotated with a
specific annotation, and then in
Spring you can define, you
can say, scan the entire class
path to try and find any of
these classes that I might
want to instantiate.
The way that Spring does this,
and the way that a lot of
other frameworks does this, is
it they take all of these JARs
that you have on your
class path.
So again, if you have a lot of
JARs, if you have a really
large deployment, this can
be even more of an issue.
It'll take all of these
different JARs.
It'll, in this case in Spring,
you can specify a
package to filter on.
In some other examples, you
might find that you can
specify regexes on the
class name and such.
But it's got to go and look at
the table of contents of every
single JAR file, if it hasn't
already, try and figure out
which class definitions it might
want to go see if they
have annotations on.
And in order to get that, to
determine if there's an
annotation on any of those
classes, it's going to read
all of those class
definitions in.
It's probably going to use ASM
or something like that to
locate the actual annotation
itself.
So you're not only reading in
the byte code, you're parsing
the byte code.
You're processing it.
And then finally, you're making
a decision of whether
or not to instantiate
the class.
So this can be really,
really problematic.
And to be perfectly honest if
you only have a few classes,
it can be this easy just to have
the class instantiated by
your framework.
And I could do even less code
than this and just write "new
simple movie listing."
So what's it look like when App
Engine app is doing a lot
of this automatic class
instantiating?
Let's take a look here.
OK.
So again, this is jMeter,
really great--
Apache jMeter, sorry-- a
really great program.
Let me make sure I've got this
all set up correctly.
What I'm looking at is, I can
define an HDP request
underneath thread group.
A thread group is where I define
how many concurrent
users and how often they're
hitting this service.
So let's give this a go.
Let me make sure I don't
have any results here.
So now I'm kind of beating
up the service again.
We can actually take a look and
see how many instances I
have a running.
And here I have a few
less instances.
Well, we haven't ramped
up all the way yet,
so let's see here.
There we go.
We're starting to get there.
And we can actually
take a look.
We should be able to graph
these at this point.
And so we're kind of now at
about 20 seconds to actually
get our first few requests in.
So this is what it looks like
whenever you have an
application that you're doing
a whole lot of work to avoid
writing a lot of code
that could pretty
easily just be written.
OK.
Code generation--
this is my code.
I wrote this a long time ago.
And every now and then, I use
something like this as an
interview question.
So if you can spot the most
terrible mistake I made in
this, grab me.
I've got office hours
and stuff later.
I'd love to chat about how
terrible this code is with
anyone who wants to tell
me how bad it is.
The reason this code is terrible
in the context of
what I'm telling you today
though is, what this is, this
is an aspect.
It's designed--
it's an around advice aspect
for Spring Aspect-Oriented
Programming--
the Spring AOP support.
And what it does,
is it actually
creates a little class.
It creates a little
bit of byte code
that wraps your class.
And whenever an exception
is thrown, it logs that
exception, and re-throws it,
which is kind of weird.
But if you look--
I don't know what
that is doing.
OK.
[INAUDIBLE].
Good.
If you take a look at this "at
around" here, this is called a
Point Cut in Aspect-Oriented
Programming.
And this Point Cut in particular
is going to be
hitting every single
public method.
So that means that for every
single public method in my
entire application, I'm going to
generate some code, and put
that in the way.
So there's a whole lot of
frameworks that just relaxed
to doing this.
This is something that you
should probably avoid when
ever you're building
new applications.
But a lot of frameworks do
run-time generation of code.
If you're working in something
and you can't really get rid
of a lot of this Aspect-Oriented
Programming,
even though it's--
I don't like it.
You could definitely do things
like use compile time
generation of the aspects,
generation of the code.
And you can also do with
aspectJ, I believe you can do
compile, like build
compile-time
class byte code weaving.
That's what I was looking for.
All right.
So what does it look like when
we have an application that
does a lot of this?
So I've got another jMeter
demo all spun up
and ready to go.
Let's make sure that--
see yep, that's right.
That's all right.
OK.
Let's give it a shot.
So we can actually go and
take a look again
and see what's happening.
Now the interesting thing about
doing a lot of class
generation is that you're
actually going to end up using
a lot of permanent generation
space in the VM to track all
of the generated classes.
And that's another thing that's
really problematic,
because it's really
hard to tune a VM.
And if you're on a platform as
a service, do you really want
to like have to really specify a
lot of tuning parameters for
your specific VMs?
It can be really, really,
really troublesome.
As you can see, we're spinning
up a lot of instances
to deal with this.
So let's take a look at what
this looks like in a graph.
Yeah, that doesn't
look too clean.
We're up at 22 seconds.
And now you're kind of seeing
this really bizarre behavior
where we didn't have
that before.
You see this kind of
arc like this.
And a lot of that is you're
going to end up spinning up
more instances over time to
try and handle that versus
like being able to really
blow through it.
And I don't really have data
points on this graph.
It's unfortunate.
OK.
Cool.
So that's kind of what
that looks like.
And as a result, that's
something you should probably
avoid doing in your
application.
It's not something that's
specific to App Engine even.
Because you're going to end up
with this kind of problem if
you're using anything, if you're
going to end up having
a lot of untuned JVMs.
So the next few are JAVA
specific, because they are
things that typically
JAVA applications
have done in the past.
Managing shared state--
it's kind of not the best idea
to do a whole lot of cross
talk between your application
instances as they're starting
up, if you're starting up a ton
of application instances
at the same time.
And so in this case, we're kind
of just grabbing some
information out of our
persistence mechanism, doing
on each request from a user.
And this can be really
problematic because you're
going to end up autoscaling
in a very brief
period of time, generally.
So all of these requests are
going to hit some service to
try and pull in all
this context.
So you have to be very careful
not to try and do too many.
You can end up doing too many
requests on start up in these
types of applications.
And caching can kind of help,
but it's not going to be the
most effective.
Another problem that goes
along the same vein is
persisting configuration.
In the last several
years, I've kind
of shifted my opinion.
I used to be really behind
having your configuration
persisted in your data store
or in your database.
The problem with this is that
again, when you have a whole
bunch of instances of your
application start up at the
same time, they'll just pound
that back-end resource.
This was a big problem back
when I worked at unnamed,
large internet retailer.
And so it's what I've come to
do, is actually just work on
trying to build that
configuration into a my source
code, into the source itself.
Build and deploy that
configuration along with my
application.
And maybe just keep a few keys
available so I can switch in
and out a few of those
properties.
Like say, I want to use the
development, my development
configuration.
I want to use my QA
configuration or
something like that.
And what you're seeing in this
code here is just kind of
something that where you're
generating some kind of shared
secret on the first request and
start trying to persist it
and re-get it.
Well, let's see what happens
whenever we have an
application that does something
like this--
see how this plays out.
So jMeter again.
We're going to spin up a bunch
instances again to see if we
can handle all this load.
And this is our App Engine
dashboard here with all the
instances that are running.
As you see here, we've got
a good deal of instances.
We're spinning up way more.
And when we take a look at this
graph, we'll see that
we're doing OK in general, but
that we're still not handling
user requests very quickly
for a little while.
We're still not nearly like
what we have here.
And unfortunately, since I'm
using the App Engine data
store as what I'm persisting all
of my stuff with it, it's
actually kind of fast and
pretty performant.
So is Memcache.
I'm sorry it's not quite as
crazy of a graph, but I could
definitely try a
little harder.
And as you can see also, I'm
spinning up tons and tons of
instances to handle this--
way more than my
other examples.
OK.
So what are some tools I've been
using and that I use to
try and work on, like
work through these
types of issues myself?
I of course like to
use my build tool.
And I think that it's incredibly
important to have a
build tool that will manage
all of the relationships
between the dependencies
in your application--
something that you can easily
analyze your entire dependency
closure and make sure you're not
bringing in a lot of stuff
you don't need.
Another thing that's really
useful is actually Proguard.
And it's something that I've
been working on trying to get
a little bit more of a paper
written up that would help
developers use that
in App Engine.
But it can really help you
reduce the amount of classes
you're deploying--
deploy only what you need.
And in those cases, you actually
have really good
cache locality when it comes
to the network file system
that's going to be providing
your application to your
individual application
instances.
So that can help a whole lot.
And then of course, I was using
Apache jMeter a lot in
all the demos.
Of course load testing-- people
are always concerned
about that, but to be honest--
well this is kind of
a crazy number.
I'm sorry.
I was going to reduce this.
But it's cost me about $9.41
to run this demo.
I don't know how
many times now.
It's not that expensive
to just do
some simple load tests.
Let's see.
AppStats is also a really
great tool.
It's really useful for a
profiling all of your back-end
RPC calls and making sure that
everything is smooth from that
perspective.
So go forth and scale.
Build applications
that scale well.
Build applications that
are very simple.
Things that you have
very strong static
analysis tools for.
And have fun.
My office hours are tomorrow
10:15 to 11 AM over at the
Cloud Sandbox.
And feel free to
come hit us up.
Are there any questions?
Please.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So, a lot of
the [INAUDIBLE].
FEMALE SPEAKER: Can he go to
the microphone, please.
MATT STEPHENSON: Yeah.
There's a microphone.
Do you want to use
a microphone?
Yeah.
Or you can repeat what
you're saying if you
don't want to use it.
Fine.
AUDIENCE: A lot of things you're
doing is trying to
simplify the application
so that the
footprint is smaller, right?
This is--
MATT STEPHENSON: Yes.
AUDIENCE: But the other hand,
a lot of framework is trying
to simplify workflow to
make things simple.
Where do you reach the balance
between writing everything in
your code versus making it
simple and tuning it?
And would you do that
first when you're
starting off a new app?
MATT STEPHENSON: That's
an interesting point.
I think that there's a really
good balance there.
And the really good balance is
usually, I actually can use
testing a lot--
testing my application, testing
assumptions of my
application--
to try and strike
that boundary.
Because if I want to really
test my application--
and the frameworks that are
associated with my application
are a part of that--
I do need to test some
assumptions about those
frameworks.
I can't just go on those
frameworks on face value.
So when it comes to trying
to leverage frameworks to
simplify the amount of code
you're writing and your code
flow, it means that you're going
to end up writing a lot
of tests to make it so that you
can be able to understand
what's going on under the covers
with those frameworks.
So at a certain point, you can
kind of strike a boundary of
like saying, look, if I
introduce this framework, I
have to think about also all the
tests that I need to write
to need to make sure I
understand all the assumptions
that I'm bringing into my
dependency closure.
From that, that kind of helps me
understand if a framework's
going to be valuable or not.
And I mean, I have to play with
it a bit, usually myself,
to make sure that it's what
I really want to use.
Was that good?
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So let's say that you finally
convinced your employer that
dependency management tools
are a good thing.
MATT STEPHENSON:
That is great.
AUDIENCE: And then they turn to
you and say, OK, we don't
want an instinctual answer.
We don't want your
gut reaction.
What we want to do is, we want
you to go and actually assess
them and report back to us
what you can about the
different tools.
We really want to make an
objective as opposed to an
emotional decision here.
Do you have any advice
for me on how to move
forward doing that?
MATT STEPHENSON: So I guess my
objective stance on that is
to, if I want to objectively
evaluate different build tools
and different dependency
management tools, it's best if
everything's kind of working
together really well.
So having something that's
very mature is useful.
But my personal preference
has ended up being
Maven for right now.
Like, I like Gradle, but Maven
ends up, everything kind of
works together, as long
as I keep it simple.
You know.
So I think that having a full
build toolset that works
together really well is
really important.
Testing that out.
And then being able to--
Oh, the other thing that's
really great is IDE
integrations, so which is like
one of the big reasons why we
got behind Maven on the App
Engine chain was because then,
all of a sudden, IntelliJ
is a lot nicer and
everything's lot nicer.
NetBeans is a lot nice.
So I would say IDE integrations
and having a tool
set that's complete and whole,
in and of itself.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
MATT STEPHENSON: Is a good?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
We use Spring MVC quite a
bit in our applications.
And you give the example of
doing the single bean
instantiations.
Can you give any other tips
for optimizing Spring MVC
applications on App Engine?
MATT STEPHENSON: Yeah.
So if you're doing, so Spring
MVC is really big on the
automatic instantiation
of classes.
And there's potentially a lot of
AOP that you can get mixed
in there if you're using some
of the security features in
Spring, I believe.
And so those two, you kind of
have to be careful with what
all you're--
whenever you're using Spring AOP
in there-- what all you're
going to be surrounding
with Advice.
And then I would also say
that trying to use lazy
initialization wherever
you can for beans.
Lazy initialization is a really
careful one though.
Because whenever you use lazy
initialization, you're going
to be creating a lot of extra
classes in the middle there.
Yeah.
And the reason to do lazy
loading is to try and amortize
all that cost of starting up
your application over time.
AUDIENCE: Great.
Thank you very much
MATT STEPHENSON: Sure.
AUDIENCE: Hey there.
Two part question.
Do you feel like--
you had a lot of good
anti-patterns.
And reducing the amount of
libraries and dependency seems
like a good idea.
Do you feel like there's a
correlation between more
realistic applications and
more larger uses of more
libraries--
as opposed to like a load driver
that you were showing?
MATT STEPHENSON: Yeah.
Yeah.
I would say that for
applications that are built
where you have a single
instantiated app--
like a single version, a
single piece of that
application is instantiated
at a time--
so if I'm building a very large
application, I generally
build a lot of different smaller
services that I'm
going to run behind
that application.
AUDIENCE: Exactly.
MATT STEPHENSON: And with those
services, each one of
those I'm pretty careful to make
sure that the dependency
closure is very minimal.
And so in a lot of cases, I can
reduce how much overhead I
have in my application
just by constraining,
like splitting services.
In a way, it's really nice to
have your services split out,
very logically.
But sometimes, if you split out
services just to be able
to keep the dependency
closure constrained--
AUDIENCE: I get it.
MATT STEPHENSON: --you can
really gain a lot of value.
AUDIENCE: Decompose
for scalability.
Yeah.
MATT STEPHENSON: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: OK.
And then I heard a couple
of other people
remark on this too.
Obviously frameworks are here
to stay and there's a lot of
value in them.
What are you guys doing to make
frameworks work better on
App Engine as opposed to
saying, hey you have to
choose, right?
Put your configuration in your
code where it's hard to manage
over time or-- you
know what I mean?
Stuff like that.
Like, what are you guys doing
to make it work better?
MATT STEPHENSON: So one thing
in particular is for Spring
MVC, if you're using the Context
Component Scan, I was
just like talking to Jurgen
over at, now I guess
Pivotal, who is--
AUDIENCE: Disclaimer.
I work for Pivotal.
MATT STEPHENSON: You
work for Pivotal.
You weren't on the phone
with me, were you?
AUDIENCE: Maybe I was.
MATT STEPHENSON: OK.
So we were talking about--
and I owe him a pull request to
try and help get some JAR
indexing in, kind of like
what JBoss does.
So they do.
They have like a project called
jandex that indexes all
these classes and indexes
the annotations on them.
And then they can actually call
back into that and create
classes that way, so you're not
going and spinning through
tons and tons of JAR files
whenever you're trying to find
classes that might have
a specific annotation.
So that's one thing that I've
been working with framework
providers to do.
And then the other thing is just
basically fixing bugs.
I'll go on there sometimes just
send pull requests to fix
bugs for things that I
see here and there.
AUDIENCE: Cool.
Thanks.
We're excited to work
with you too.
MATT STEPHENSON: Cool.
AUDIENCE: It seems a lot of the
discussion that you had is
around optimizing
start-up times.
MATT STEPHENSON: Yes.
AUDIENCE: And that is especially
important when you
have a lot of smaller
instances.
MATT STEPHENSON: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Does App Engine, or
will it ever support more
coarse-grained scaling, such
that you have fewer instances
and therefore less of this
kind of problem?
MATT STEPHENSON: So are you
asking about having larger
instance types, or?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
MATT STEPHENSON: OK.
So we have F1, F2, F4.
F4s are pretty big for
front-end instances.
And we also back-end
instances.
And I think probably if you come
to the office hours, or
if you actually cover to the
cloud booth later, I can point
you to the guy-- or I can make
sure I find his office hours--
who is working, Troy, who is
working on the servers
project, which would be like
really along the lines of what
you're thinking about,
I think.
Which allows you to have much
heavier weight machines.
AUDIENCE: But that's something
that the developer would have
to look at specifically and say,
we can't make this start
up any faster.
MATT STEPHENSON: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: We're going to have
to go with a different
instance size.
MATT STEPHENSON: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: There's really no--
AUDIENCE: OK
MATT STEPHENSON: There's a
couple of other projects going
on now, like CapeDwarf is an
open source alternative to App
Engine that's capable
of running
on some larger instances.
AUDIENCE: How do you handle
applications with very large
memory footprint in the App
Engine world, like where they
would like to load a lot of
static content in memory like
10 gig, 20 gig?
Do you find issues with the
garbage collection?
MATT STEPHENSON: Yes.
Very large applications--
first of all, if you have too
large of a memory footprint,
it just won't start,
because we do very
small instance sizes.
AUDIENCE: So is there a limit?
Like, what is the maximum you
can go in App Engine?
MATT STEPHENSON: There is.
I would have to pull
it all up.
I believe for F1s, it's like,
it's pretty small.
It's 128 megs.
Like, we have really
small instances.
And then we get up to
I believe one or
two gigs on an instance?
Maybe it's half a gig.
I would have to go look it up.
I don't remember off
the top of my head,
but it's pretty small.
So running a lot, consuming a
lot of memory on an individual
instance can be problematic
from that regard.
It also can take a little while
to get the instance up
and running because it's
just going to be--
you're going to be continuously
trying to
allocate memory inside
of the instance.
And if you're in a really,
really overprovisioned
environment, you
could end up--
even outside of App Engine, if
you're using something like
OpenStack Tiny Instances and
trying to autoscale with
something like that--
then you can end up with, if
you're oversubscribed for
memory on the machine, then you
can end up actually like
the virtualization software
actually starts swapping out
some of that memory.
So you end up with a lot of
problems if you're consuming
tons and tons of memory.
AUDIENCE: But if you have
applications which are like
loading a lot of content, and
they require like eight or 10
gigs, how do you guys handle the
garbage collection part?
You continuously try to optimize
the JVM parameters?
Are you trying to--
MATT STEPHENSON: Yeah.
Yeah.
We're always looking at them and
trying to optimize them.
AUDIENCE: OK.
And is the JVM used in the App
Engine is the same from the
Oracle like HotSpot one, or is
it a different flavor of it?
MATT STEPHENSON: I don't know if
I should say on camera too
much about that, but
it's pretty close.
You wouldn't notice
the difference.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hey.
How's it going?
I'm not on App Engine now, but
I'm considering about using
App Engine.
And one of the questions I have
is actually about being
able to profile, right?
MATT STEPHENSON: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I'm assuming
you don't get to
profile in the box.
How do you guys manage being
able to use some sort of
profiling tool or what do you
guys suggest to profiling your
application that at least
replicates some sort of
environment on the cloud?
MATT STEPHENSON: So I've been
trying to look at building
better profiling tools
for developers.
There's some stuff that we have
helped people with in the
past along those lines--
larger customers.
It's very difficult to make
something like that really
work well, where it's not
interfering with your
application.
But AppStats is really great for
profiling all of your out
of the VM calls.
So all of your calls to like
going to getting things from
the data store, things like
that, AppStats is really
effective for.
AUDIENCE: Does AppStats provide,
for instance you were
talking about on start up--
class creation and things that
happen on start up-- does
AppStats provide insights
into that, or?
MATT STEPHENSON: No.
AUDIENCE: Mind you,
I apologise.
I'm not so familiar
with App Engine.
MATT STEPHENSON: No, not yet.
But like I said, not yet.
I was actually going
to try and hack
that in at some point.
That was one of the things,
that's one thing that I'm
looking at, is how to get a lot
more of those statistics
out there in a way that it's
going to just be information
that's pertinent to you.
Because right now, if I try kind
of shoving those types of
metrics in, I have to be a
little bit delicate not to
mung up what we're doing with
what you're doing in your
application.
AUDIENCE: Right, Yeah, it's
extremely important I think
for like super large scale usage
to be able to dive into
your application and see what's
happening, so if you
get around to ha hacking
into it--
MATT STEPHENSON: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: --it will
be very useful.
Thank you.
MATT STEPHENSON: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Could you talk about
how whether you use Omega
behind App Engine?
MATT STEPHENSON: I couldn't
hear you too well.
AUDIENCE: Can you talk about
whether you use Omega behind
the App Engine?
MATT STEPHENSON: Omega?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
MATT STEPHENSON: I'm not
familiar with it.
AUDIENCE: That's
the [INAUDIBLE]
scaling system.
You have people on that.
Google research has
people on that.
MATT STEPHENSON: I'm having
a hard time hearing.
AUDIENCE: It's like the Mesos
thing you developed.
MATT STEPHENSON: Oh.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
MATT STEPHENSON: Yeah.
To my knowledge, no, we don't.
AUDIENCE: OK.
AUDIENCE: I got here a little
late, so I'm sorry if this
question's been answered.
But I've had the opposite
problem, where I have really,
really small request servlets.
And I think there's a limit in
App Engine that you can only
have like 10 concurrent
requests
handled by one instance.
Is there any plan to
increase that?
I think it was some legacy
thing with memory issues.
Like, what's your reasoning
behind it?
Is there a story around this?
MATT STEPHENSON: Those types of
limitations have been with
it for a long time--
been with App Engine
for a long time.
And a lot of them do need
to be reevaluated.
So I would say, yeah, I'm happy
to take a look and see
what we can do about that.
That's a good suggestion.
You can hit me up on
Stack Overflow.
You can hit me up on the App
Engine IRC channel and
Freenode too.
AUDIENCE: Cool.
MATT STEPHENSON: And, yeah,
let's chat about doing that.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
Thank you.
MATT STEPHENSON: I like that.
AUDIENCE: Does this [INAUDIBLE]
problem with
Guice, when you use Guice
with App Engine?
MATT STEPHENSON: Oh, Guice.
I like using Guice a lot.
There is a couple things in
Guice that are kind of weird
that I avoid.
The circular proxies in Guice
create a lot of problems with
creating extra classes
to deal with--
you haven't had both classes
fully initialize yet.
And circular proxy is
just kind of weird.
And then I try to avoid
automatic injection, but
that's more of just a personal
preference, I think.
The thing that can kind of go
sideways with App Engine and
Guice is if you have a whole lot
of modules, whole lot of
separate modules are all being
composed together.
I'm kind of cold on
this question.
I haven't looked at this in
about two months now.
So I'm trying to get my context
back, but I believe
there's a validation step that
Guice goes through that does
end up doing a good deal
of introspection of the
application's class path that
can be problematic like that.
Is that good?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I don't know how much
more time I have.
Any more questions?
Cool.
Well, I'm here all week.
I'll be--
me and Ludov will both
be at office
hours tomorrow at 10:15.
That's kind of the official
time to come find us.
But I'm going to be running
around the conference a little
bit, but mostly over
at the cloud desk.
I'll also be helping out
with the Atlas--
the, sorry, cloud data
store code lab at
the end of the week.
And so, that should
be pretty fun.